Good morning, greets Sally Jaramillo,
the snow continued to fall in the
Las Vegas Valley. On Tuesday, residents
shared photos and videos.
Most of the snow fell northwest of the
city in the exam region, where
residents enjoyed early morning
The accumulation of the precious white powder
Nevada continues to occupy the last place in
the distribution of the
coronavirus vaccine and health sector officials
are requesting more vaccines
than they have received, they also want to
ensure that people who have already received
their first dose do not forget to get vaccinated
With the second dose, for this very reason, they
are contacting
eligible people to schedule their appointments for the
second dose that will be available next
week. Clark County
will receive 23,000 more vaccines this week,
but officials say
four times this
amount can be administered per  what they are requesting
is increased shipping
a woman from las vegas is accused  of
killing his 4-year-old stepson,
Arleth, 29, was arrested on
Friday, according to detectives from the
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police. The father of the
minor, Marx, the junior pastor, can
work leaving his son with Arleth.
hospital where he was
pronounced dead but later
indicted in court on tuesday
the city of las vegas seeks to help
low-income seniors with
their taxes so it is
offering
seniors a refund of
taxes paid on  its public services for
the year 2020 the services include
electricity, gas and telephone there are some
requirements to qualify these are
available on our
website new sound dotcom
and the city also opened the
enrollment of brick kinder in its
strawn academies which are the
pre-school classes  kindergarten had been closed since
mid-December due to the
pandemic but families now  you can
enroll students the classes are
free for families in certain zip codes
the city is also
offering mobile click er and
noon classes among other activities
now we move on with the
weather forecast a day with clouds and
little sun is expected maximum of  today it will be 48
degrees and more rain is coming to
end the week have a good day
I am salt and jaramillo and this was in
disney in Spanish
[Music]